if you spend any time driving around
America recently you may have noticed
that an awful lot of the country seems
to have shriveled up and died take a
trip on route 2 in Maine sometime and
count the boarded up paper mills and
abandoned houses you see we're headed
down Route 23 in Michigan or Ohio and
consider the empty factories ringed with
barbed wire you'll see a lot of them
outside the coastal cities scenes like
this are everywhere this is your country
now shuttered car dealerships next to
defunct restaurants across street from
thrift stores and methadone clinics
that's America community after community
desiccated empty husks with nothing left
huge swaths the United States look like
that now so what happened well a lot of
things happen some of them are
complicated and hard to change but one
of the big factors in the slow-moving
disaster is the utter transformation of
the way our leaders think about the
American economy during the last Gilded
Age 125 years ago America's ruling class
may have been ostentatiously rich and
they were go to Newport Rhode Island for
proof if you like but it was still a
recognizably American class tycoons
accumulated fortunes but they also felt
some obligation to the country around
them steel kite tycoon Andrew Carnegie
famously built stone libraries around
the country for the edification of
people beneath him john d rockefeller
and many others so-called robber barons
set aside huge portions of their wealth
and in some cases their property to make
this country better
Yellowstone Acadia National Park etc
maybe most significantly in January of
1914 Henry Ford more than doubled the
prevailing factory wage - with then
remarkable $5 for an eight-hour day Ford
didn't have to do that but his company
was succeeding any thought he should
some historians trace the creation of
the American middle-class to that
decision either way it is nearly
impossible to imagine a big company
doing anything like that today attitudes
are just too different your average
finance mogul looks at workers merely as
cost to be reduced or eliminated
entirely private equity isn't building a
lot of public libraries these days
instead the model is ruthless economic
efficiency by a distressed company out
sorts the jobs liquidate
the valuable assets fire middle
management and once the smoke is cleared
dump what remains to the highest bidder
often in Asia it's happened around the
country it has made a small number of
people phenomenally rich one of them is
a new york-based hedge fund manager
called Paul singer according to forbes
has amassed a personal fortune of more
than three billion dollars how was
singer made that money we made a lot of
it by purchasing sovereign debt from
financially distressed countries
countries that were in trouble usually
at a massive discount once the country's
economy regains some stability singer
would bombard its government with
lawsuits of a massive public relations
campaign originating here in Washington
sometimes until he made his money back
with interest the practice is called
vulture capitalism feeding off the
carcass of a dying nation in some ways
it's not so different from what singer
and his firm Elliott management have
done in this country and to this country
over the past couple of decades Elliott
management has been billions by buying
large stakes in American companies then
firing workers driving up short-term
share prices and in some cases taking
government bailouts insult to injury
Bloomberg News once described singer as
quote the world's most feared investor
and that tells you a lot no one's even
pretending Paul singers tactics are good
for anyone but Paul singer and his fund
consider the case of Delphi the
automotive parts supplier during the
last financial crisis a consortium of
hedge funds including singers Elliott
Management purchased Delphi with singer
and the other funds at the helm the
company took billions of dollars in
government bailouts paid for by you
Obama's autos are compared those tactics
to extortion but they continued anyway
once they had the bailout money the
funds moved most of Delphi jobs overseas
and then either cut retiree pensions
entirely or shifted the cost to
taxpayers with later financial
commitments at home and cheap factories
abroad Delphi stock soared
according to investigative reporter Greg
Palast of the twenty-nine Delphi plants
and operational in the hedge fund
started buying Delphi his debt only four
we're still operating in the United
States by 2012 that means tens of
thousands of unionized and white-collar
workers lost their jobs
Paul singer's hedge fund cashed out for
more than a billion dollars
see how that works well some countries
including the United Kingdom have banned
this kind of behavior it bears no
resemblance whatsoever to the capitalism
we were promised in school
it creates nothing it destroys entire
cities
it couldn't be uglier or more
destructive so why is this so allowed in
the United States
the short answer because people like
Paul singer have tremendous influence
over our political process singer
himself was the second largest donor to
the Republican Party in 2016
he's given millions to a super PAC that
supports Republican senators you may
never have heard of Paul singer which
tells you a lot in itself but in
Washington he is rock star famous and
that may be why he's almost certainly
paying a lower effective tax rate than
your average fireman just in case you're
still wondering if our system is rigged
oh yeah it is tonight we want to tell
you a little more about how Paul singer
does business the story begins in a
small town called Sidney Nebraska
population 6282
two hours outside Denver say Sydney is
the longtime home of the sporting goods
retailer Cabela's which sells fishing
and hunting gear in October of 2015
singer's hedge fund disclosed an 11
percent stake in Cabela's instead about
pushing the board to sell the company
Cabela's management apparently fearing a
long and costly fight with singer
announced it would look for a buyer now
at the time Cabela's was a relatively
healthy company it was posting nearly
two billion dollars a year in gross
profits off four billion dollars in
revenue there didn't seem to be any
immediate need to sell but Cabela's sold
anyway after being pushed so one year
after singer entered the equation Bass
Pro Shops announced the purchase of
Cabela's the company's stock price
surged within a week literally a week
Paul singer cashed out he bought the
stock for $38 a share he sold it for 63
dollars a share his hedge fund made at
least 90 million dollars upfront and
likely more over time but in Sidney
Nebraska it was a very different story
the residents of Sidney did not get rich
know just the opposite
their community was devastated destroyed
the town lost nearly 2,000 jobs a
heartbreakingly familiar cascade began
the left property values collapsed and
then people couldn't leave they were
trapped there
one of the last thriving small towns in
this country went under we recently sent
two producers to Sydney Nebraska to
survey the wreckage there and to
consider what happened our producers
talked to more than a dozen former
Cabela's employees almost all of them
refused to speak to us on camera fearful
of legal retribution from the famously
vicious Paul singer but off-camera they
told us their story here it is
Sydney is it's a great place to be this
is Sydney Nebraska a small town two
hours outside of Denver for decades a
sporting goods retailer the Bellas kept
its headquarters in
as the company grew more prosperous so
did the town Cabela's was the Keystone
employer our model forever was
small-town values big time opportunities
but that motto was turned on its head
when Elliott Management Corporation
that's a new york-based hedge fund
managed by billionaire Paul singer took
an ownership stake in Cabela's when we
got the news this company is coming in
from New York City and buying a huge
stake in Cabela's that shakes things up
at the time Cabela's was making more
than a billion dollars of the year but
Paul singer's firm sensed it could make
a quick buck by driving up the stock
price by forcing a merger once thriving
town of Sydney lost everything that's
how a longtime Cabela's employee reacted
to news that she was losing her job
probably looking at around 2000 jobs
2,000 jobs gone yeah Sydney was
devastated a good American town and just
destroyed it
Tim O'Connell runs the town's lumberyard
before the merger business was great we
were just buried you know with with
business now his customer base has
collapsed how many new homes have been
built since Cabela's and Bass Pro merged
in the city limits here there
one house before Paul singer's hedge
fund put Cabela's in its sights
Sydney was experiencing a building boom
we're gonna build a new housing
subdivision to meet housing needs all
these great things are happening and
instead we are working our tails off to
try to figure out a way to survive
for the people of Sydney it's been a
disaster those who want to leave Sydney
can't go housing values have collapsed
tethering them there for those who want
to stay it's almost impossible to find a
job how long does it take you to find a
new job as Sydney collapsed Wall Street
cashed in Paul singers hedge fund sold
out before the merger was even complete
the fund made nearly a hundred million
dollars Paul singer is proud of what he
did if money is that big of a god - it
was pretty secular being well as we were
doing that story we were warned
repeatedly by people around Washington
don't criticize Paul singer that's not a
good idea and as that package played I
got the following text from a very
well-known person in Washington holy
smokes I can't believe you're doing this
I'm afraid of Paul singer we'll see what
happens meanwhile Ben Sasse and this may
point to the point the texture was
making Ben Sasse is the US Senator
represents the state of Nebraska Sydney
of course isn't that large but you might
think the death of a town in his state
would be of concern to Ben Sasse again
u.s. senator from Nebraska but so far it
doesn't seem like he's ever commented on
what's happened to Sydney we looked hard
then we called sasses office to see if
they could point to a time where he
commented on the destruction of Sydney
or simply supply a statement to us
about what happened there the Ben sasses
office didn't even respond to our
producers huh
that's odd but then here's one possible
explanation for that
during his Senate run Ben Sasse received
the largest possible donation from Paul
singer